[Musique]
en tant que pays en tant que continent
pouvons poursuivre l'excellence en nous
privant de dick le sens de nos capacités
de 25%
pouvons-nous être dans une démarche
d'excellence sans nous appuyer
pleinement sur la moitié de nos
capacités
je travaille pour l'agente de
développement de l'humain ficales
initialement connue hommage ans d'une
école
selon le mandat qui nous a été donnée
par les chefs d'état et de gouvernement
des 55 états membres de l'union
africaine
mon rôle consiste à soutenir les états
membres pour la conception et la mise en
oeuvre d'initiatives de projets et de
programmes de développement dans le cas
de mes responsabilités
la question du genre s'est imposée à moi
très tôt non pas parce que je suis une
femme non pas parce que je me définis
comme étant féministe c'est à dire que
je considère que les femmes sont des
êtres humains autonome a qui doivent
être donnés les mêmes opportunités que
les hommes
la question s'est imposée à moi de
manière pragmatique les pays africains
confort et devient alors évident qu'il
n'est pas possible de se développer
pleinement sans prendre en compte cette
moitié de la population dans mon milieu
on parle souvent de l'autonomisation des
femmes comme pouvant contribuer
personnellement je rejette ce terme je
considère plus les femmes sont aux
normes par nature il suffit de les
observer dans un environnement où elles
ne sont pas montre avait l'environnement
domestique par exemple
ou non seulement à se prenne en charge
de manière autonome sur les aspects
logistiques mais elles prennent en
charge très souvent également un
plusieurs voir tous les autres membres
du foyer
donc pour moi la question n'est pas
celle de l'autonomisation qui se posent
un processus visant à rendre les femmes
autonomes
la question est plus de savoir comment
préserver cette nature autonome et
comment lui permettre de s'exprimer dans
tous les aspects de la vie au terme de
tenue mise à sion je préfère celui de
pouvoir d' agences qui est la capacité à
prendre des décisions et à les mettre en
oeuvre
de nombreuses études existent et qui
font le lien entre le pouvoir d'agencés
la capacité des femmes pour participer
au processus de décision politique
économique et financier pour ma part je
pense que le pouvoir d' agences et comme
un muscle que nous développons avec
notre capacité à nous investir pour
notre propre développement et à nous
placer dans des conditions qui
permettent à ce pouvoir d' agences de
s'exprimer et c'est pour cela que je
voudrais aujourd'hui ont proposé une
grille de lecture en deux dimensions
alors je dois vous prévenir cette grille
de lecture une fois vous le réutiliser
deux ou trois fois
vous ne pourrez plus l'oublier elle est
contagieuse
c'est une grille de lecture qui
s'applique à de nombreuses circonstances
de nombreuses situations de la vie
sociale et même domestique
elle est très simple et elle tient en de
nous engueuler outre l'espace et le
temps
lorsque j'observe un groupe de personnes
en situation d'apprentissage en
situation de prise de
dans un contexte à forte charge
symbolique
je ne peux pas m'empêcher d'observer et
d'analyser si la gestion de l'espace
reproduit les inégalités de genre ou si
elle permet de noter des avancées
quelle est la proportion de femmes dans
l'assistance quelle est la proportion de
femmes pour répondre à celle où les
femmes sont peut être positionné dans la
salle parce qu'elles sont debout comme
trop souvent le cas de nos hôtesses qui
sont malheureusement trop souvent les
seuls jeunes femmes à accéder à certains
espaces
est ce qu'elles sont les seules à être
assise par terre comme on le voit
souvent dans le milieu rural
qu'est ce que la gestion de l'espace
véhicule comme message qui est dans
l'action qui est décisionnaire qui est
bénéficiaire qui est présent pour
exprimer des doléances et qui est
présente pour les recevoir
finalement pour qui cet espace est il
conçu et qui dit est juste tolérés
lorsque je constate qu'il ya une
majorité d'hommes
je ne peux pas m'empêcher de me demander
ce que font les femmes
à cet instant précis ce qui m'amène à la
deuxième dimension de la grille de
lecture qui est celle du temps une femme
africaine consacrent en moyenne cinq
heures par jour au travail nourri
gouvernement en d'autres termes près de
30 % de son temps est consacré aux soins
des enfants pour soi des personnes âgées
et au travail domestique
or les journées et ont 24 heures pour
tout le monde c'est du temps que cette
femme ne consacre pas à son enfant
au développement à son apprentissage et
même à ses loisirs et à son repos qui
lui permettrait d'être plus efficace par
ailleurs dans sa contribution à la vie
de la cité
donc au lieu de simplement déploré le
manque de représentation des femmes dans
les simples d' influence décision au
pouvoir au lieu de l'attribuer à un
manque d'intérêt un manque d'ambition ou
un manque de compétences des femmes
il ya lieu de se souvenir qu'il a tout
un système et des parcours qui
permettent le développement des
potentiels et il ya lieu de se demander
quels sont les mécanismes qui
interdisent aux femmes
l'entrée dans la fabrique des talents
que font les petites filles
lorsque les garçons ça donne au football
ou autres sports collectifs qu'ils
permettent d'intégrer très tôt les
notions de travail équipés de respect
des règles
que font les jeunes filles du sahel
quand les garçons se réunissent autour
du thé pour commenter l'actualité et
s'initier au débat d'idées que font les
femmes et les mères de famille quand les
responsables d'organisations politiques
ou de la société civile se réunissent le
soir après le travail
lorsque l'on adapte ses grilles de
lecture selon l'espace et le temps les
solutions que ce soit au niveau
individuel et collectif s'impose tout
naturellement
quel que soit notre pouvoir de décision
nous avons la capacité d'influencer la
gestion de l'espace que
nous avons tous la capacité de créer des
espaces où les femmes sont non seulement
tolérés mais également accueilli est
libre de contribuer en toute liberté
sans crainte pour leur réputation leur
sécurité et sans subir de pression
inapproprié nous avons tous la capacité
de véhiculer l'idée selon laquelle les
femmes ont leur place non seulement dans
la salle mais à la table des décisions
[Applaudissements]
nous avons tous la capacité de permettre
aux petites filles de grandir avec
l'idée selon laquelle leur temps à la
même valeur que celui d'un garçon
singulier également à une jeune fille de
son temps peut être investi en priorité
à ses études à ses centres d'intérêt et
à ses loisirs pour permettre aux femmes
de libérer du temps de chercheurs nommé
quentin voulons et bénédicte delabrière
propose trois choses reconnaître le
travail non rémunéré comme étant du
travail de le réduire et 3 de
redistribuer pour reconnaître le temps
de travail non rémunéré comme étant du
travail
nous avons besoin d'un changement de
paradigme dans changement de mentalité
on dit souvent que tout travail mérite
salaire
or nous avons vu que les femmes
consacrent 30 % de leur temps à un
travail qu'elles fournissent
gratuitement
micky est absolument nécessaire à la
bonne marche de la société
c'est un travail qui a permis à la
plupart d'entre nous de nous réveiller
dans une maison propre de prendre deux
trois repas par jour de mettre nos
habits propres est repassée et d'aller
contribuer à la vie de la cité
donc c'est un travail qui n'appelle pas
un salaire mais c'est un travail qui
doit être reconnu comme étant
effectivement du travail et il doit être
reconnu dans sa contribution à toutes
les réalisations de tous les hommes de
l'histoire
ensuite il s'agit de le réduire
nous avons vu comment les
infrastructures d'eau et d'électricité
par exemple permettent de réduire
considérablement le temps de travail
nous avons tous en tête l'image des
petites filles et des jeunes filles qui
doivent chercher de l'eau avant d'aller
à l'école
nous savons aussi comment l'arrivée de
l'électricité et des moulins à grain au
moulin à céréales permettent de réduire
les temps consacrés au traitement des
céréales
enfin que le travail non rémunéré est
reconnu comme accident du travail
il devient en plus aisées plus
acceptable de le redistribuer dans le
cadre d'un projet de formation
professionnelle agricole que nous
mettons en oeuvre organa nous avons
intégré dès la conception la possibilité
pour les étudiantes de faire garder
leurs enfants sur place
ces solutions de garde y intégrer nous
ont permis non seulement d'améliorer
drastiquement le taux de présence des
femmes mais également la proportion de
femmes terminant la formation c'est une
solution qui est de plus en plus proposé
par les employeurs et même les
organisateurs de conférences et cela
tombe sous le sens lorsque l'on sait que
pratiquement toutes les femmes toutes
les mères que vous connaissez ont eu un
jour
non c'est une journée de travail ou à
une opportunité en raison d'un problème
de garde donc pour permettre aux jeunes
filles aux filles et aux femmes de
participer à la course pour l'excellence
il ya lieu de reconnaître le temps de
travail non rémunéré comme exemple
travail de le réduire et de le
redistribuer travailler dans le
développement international est pour moi
source de beaucoup de doutes et de très
peu de certitudes
l'une de ses certitudes et que au delà
de l'idéologie
au delà de la morale qui nous
commanderait de frire aux femmes les
mêmes opportunités qu homme
la question du genre s'impose par son
pragmatisme nous devons réfléchir
collectivement et individuellement à
l'espace qu'occupe nos filles ou jeunes
filles et nos formes et à la manière
dont elles occupent leur temps
c'est pour moi la seule manière pour le
continent africain d'un jour atteindre
l'excellence
merci
[Applaudissements]